manhattan prosecutors have officially
charged the trump organization
and its cfo allen weisselberg with
scheming to avoid paying taxes on more
than one million dollars worth of fringe
benefits over 15 years
this marks the first set of criminal
charges against the former president's
business
the indictment accuses the trump
organization of giving weisselberg
and other staffers perks such as free
apartments and car leases
that weren't reported as income for tax
purposes dating back to at least 2005
weisselberg in particular was accused of
avoiding taxes on 1.7 million dollars in
perks
including rent and utilities for a
manhattan apartment
private school tuition for his family
leases on two mercedes
benzes furniture and flat screen tvs
both the trump organization and
weisselberg have pleaded not guilty
weisselberg has also claimed he is not a
new york city resident
which allows him to avoid paying city
income tax
in a statement trump lawyer ron fascetti
characterized the charges as quote
a sad day for the manhattan district
attorney's office and suggested the d.a
cyrus vance is leading a politically
motivated investigation
trump himself has also lashed out saying
the charges are a political witch hunt
by
quote radical left democrats the
investigation into the trump
organization began
two years ago initially with a focus on
a 2016 hush money payment
to adult film star stormy daniels and
expanding
from there prosecutors are reportedly
pressing weisselberg to cooperate with
the investigation
by offering up more information about
the company and trump
you